during the early stages when you were
thinking about not having any magic at
all in it wouldnt be any sorcery there
wouldn't be any being alien that'd just
be like an alternative history yeah that
was one thing that I went went back and
forth with in the in the very early days
you know I love all of these subgenres
of imaginative fiction horror science
fiction fantasy but in my earliest days
as a writer I think although I did some
fantasies I did some horror stories
I was permed primarily known as a
science fiction writer and I still think
I have a science fiction mindset I have
a I have a rationalist mindset that
always box a little at at magic
I prefer as a reader I prefer low magic
fantasies to you know high magic
fantasies and always have so when I'm
when I begin this and I'm writing it I
said well to what extent do I want to
have any any magic so I was you know if
you look at fever dream my my vampire
novel it's almost a science fictional
treatment of vampires because I when I
approached the vampire legends in that
book again my rationalism took over and
I said hey it was this you know they
can't cross running water what hell
can't take cross running water why don't
their reflections show up in mirrors
that makes no sense according to
everything we know according to how
light works and what mirrors actually
are well you know I mean that's that's
actually a a relic of of religious
beliefs that that vampire supposedly
have no souls and there's a soul
reflected in the mirror well of course
we know it's not actually the soul being
reflected in the mirror
it's just that light so I rationalize my
vampires they're still hopefully work as
vampires they're pretty scary but
they're another race that's
it's evolved among us through the
centuries and have always always been
there and they have certain abilities
that were they're very tough to kill but
they're not they can't turn into a mist
they came across all the running water
they want you know one of the vampires
and my books too precisely because he
knows the legends and he wants to
eliminate any any possibility of being
mistaken for vampires it fills the
entire boat with mirrors so I really
conceded that him and his friends were
all reflecting in the mirrors so I was
playing with that and I did consider a
similar approach with uh with Game of
Thrones I should I actually have dragons
or should I wear should a Targaryen have
some sort of I don't know pyrokinetic
power where they can you know almost ESP
they can manipulate flame and conjure a
blast of flame you know invisible kind
of mind dragons or something like that I
went back and forth but I finally
decided now I'm gonna I'm gonna go with
the Dragons and I think that was the I
think that was the best choice but even
there I I've applied as much rationalism
to my dragons as you can I mean did I
look at pictures of dragons in other
people's fantasies and all that this
this piece could never fly I mean they
look at the size of the belt it says the
brontosaurus would a pair of bat wings
back it's got these little bitty wings
and it's got four limbs and this
enormous belly and it's it's too heavy
you know so I've my dragons are much
more serpentine their slender their
wings are huge in compared to the the
body size and I keep everything stressed
as to the artists you know not six limbs
not four legs plus two wings they four
legs are the front wings and now
heroically that's a wyvern another
dragon which I'm perfectly aware of but
you know there are no six-limbed things
in nature you look at bats or birds they
don't have little forelegs in addition
to the wings the wings are the the four
legs so again my rationalism
creeping in and you know there I've done
panels at conventions where I've argued
this points with other fantasy writers
name their [ __ ] dragons who the hell
cares they couldn't exist anyway you
know you're never gonna have a flying
lizard you know a big enormous lizard it
flies and he's a flame but and that's
that's true I can't argue with that
yes it's not a and McCaffrey did our
best to sort of make science fiction
dragons and even there it I don't know
that it entirely works but my fantasy
dragons would never work what they're
more likely to work than other people
start to see Greg and so I'm pleased
with them and I like them I liked him
better so yes so I just decided to do as
a fantasy but a very low magic fantasy
and the original plan was that a game of
Thrones was supposed to end when event
called the red wedding which didn't
quite look out at this point I think in
previous interviews he said that a game
of Thrones was supposed to end with the
birth of Danny's dragons as it does but
the other events were supposed to be
more further along yeah then then they
were as I approached thirteen hundred
and fourteen hundred and fifteen hundred
pages and writing that book and Danny's
story was finished I had written the
birth of dragons but the stories of some
of the other characters weren't nearly
to where I wanted them to be so that's
when I decided it had to be another book
so I restructured some of the chapters
somewhat and you know I had had the
ending I had Danny I knew that was a
good way to go out with the with the
book and and the the death of Ned was
always supposed to be a very important
event toward the end of the book and the
shattering of the stark family symbol
that's how I got to that point do you
have an ending in mind do you have a
source structure in your head if a very
rough one
for the entire series yeah yeah yeah I
do but you can't know what it is have to
keep reading I'm sorry so from what from
the very start it had this idea that it
was going to be rotating POV between
different characters yeah I I've I've
added POVs perhaps more than I thought I
you know I I determined early on that
that first chap that I wrote all the way
back in 1991 was a brand checker so and
like I said that chapter almost wrote
itself in some ways a couple of the most
crucial decisions I made about the books
that have determined the thing happened
immediately after the completion of that
chapter and one of them was okay is this
a book in which bran is to hero do I now
write another chapter from brans point
of view or the third chapter from branch
point of view is this branch book or
will I use multiple viewpoints and
obviously the next chapter was from from
Catlins viewpoints so I decided to use
multiple viewpoints the other issue was
was a an issue of chronology which I
sometimes wonder if I made the right
choice on you know my original concept
was that time would pass through these
book said that the kids would grow up
more and you know years would would pass
within the course of the books itself
you know you would have a chapter and
then you'd have another chapter and
there'd be like be month and a half
later and then the next chapter would be
three months later so by the time you
finished a book four or five years would
have passed but I got away from that
almost right from the beginning because
that second chapter occurs literally
within minutes of the end of the first
chapter you know in the first chapter
they find the dire wolf pups and in the
second chapter
Ned is cleaning his sword from just
having ridden back from executing the
guy
cat comes in and tells them that Robert
is is coming so there's no there's no
time lapse there and that sort of set
the tenor for everything that followed
would with one event following very
quickly after another event and it
distorted be that way
because if something is going to happen
then you switch to another viewpoint
that character is going to respond to
what just happened he's not gonna wait
six months to respond or three months to
respond he's got to respond as soon as
he hears about it or as soon as he
affects him or what the circumstances
are but of course the result of that was
that the total booked occupied a much
smaller span of time than I had
originally envisioned and and in
particular that the kids weren't getting
very much older so at a certain point I
started thinking about this famous
infamous five-year gap that after Storm
of Swords I would leap forward five
years to let the kids get older and when
I finished all the swords I did try to
write with the five-year gap and that
was a disaster the five-year gap didn't
work it was a bad idea it worked for
some characters but it really was a
ludicrously bad way of handling some
other characters so I finally had to
trash that and along with about a year's
work trying to make that work as well
and so now we have the the story and the
present thing and more more viewpoint
characters have come in the story has
gotten progressively bigger and more
complicated which is probably one reason
why I've slowed down I mean I was never
a fast writer to begin with these people
do all these charts at all that showing
how fast I turned out the books in the
early days you know come on
I started writing the book in 1991 it
first came out in 1996
you know yes I was doing other things
I'm still doing other things but I've
never been a fast writer I've never had
a very good record of meeting deadlines
[Applause]
sorry not my fault I blew the deadline
[Laughter]
can't even mention deadlines
[Laughter]